- [Woman] Isn't everything
we're doing in life
a way to be loved a little more?
- Hi, there.
I'm Aria, and I'm looking for my soulmate.
I began my search a few months ago,
and although that story ultimately
didn't have a happy ending,
I now find myself in Vienna,
the setting for one of my
favorite films of all time.
In Before Sunrise, two strangers
spend one incredible night
wandering the city together
before going their separate ways.
And since I'm leaving
Vienna tomorrow morning,
I figure what better way to
spend my final night here
than by trying to recreate
that magic with a stranger.
Could I ask you a quick question?
- Yeah, of course.
- So, this is my last night in Vienna,
and I'm looking for someone
to explore it with me
for the evening.
- Oh.
(speaking French)
- I'm going to a birthday party.
- We gotta go home and study.
- I'm working.
- No, no.
I'm getting rejected left and right.
(speaking French)
This is gonna be harder than I thought.
How confident are you feelin' Shoshana?
Scale of one to 10.
- Hm, I'm gonna say a solid seven.
- I don't know if you know
MQ, it's MuseumsQuartier.
There's a lot of young people.
- I would love to, but
I cannot say for sure.
- It could be going better,
but I'm optimistic.
- Alright, let's go to
the Mariahilfer Strabe.
- I only have two hours left.
- I'm sorry.
- Okay, well, this is good.
I get rejected a lot tonight,
it builds up my tolerance.
So sorry to bother you,
but could I ask you a quick question?
My name's Aria.
What's your name?
Nice to meet you.
This is gonna sound crazy, okay?
It's my last night in Vienna.
I leave tomorrow morning,
and we're looking to find someone
to come explore the city with me tonight,
and I'm wondering if you
would be able to join us.
- Sure.
- She said sure?
She said sure.
(laughing)
Really, for sure?
- Of course.
- I don't know if we should cheer.
- [All] Yay!
- This is my first time in Vienna.
- First time?
- Yeah.
- When did you come here?
- I arrived two days ago.
- Two days?
- Two days ago.
- How did you like it so far?
- I love it.
I live in LA, and...
- Okay, I've been there.
- Oh, yeah, when were you in LA?
- Yeah, it's like some years ago,
but I was there for exchange but not LA.
- Oh, really?
- No, sadly, no.
- What did you go to exchange?
- Wisconsin.
- You went to Wisconsin, oh, wow.
So, you're from Vienna, born and raised?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Oh, wow, so you must have
some Vienna fun facts to share.
- I don't know, it's...
I don't know, it's just...
It's so different if you're
raised and live here.
I don't really have too
much comparison, you know?
- But you love the city?
- Yes.
(speaking Austrian)
Yeah, (speaking Austrian).
- What's a (speaking Austrian)?
- Big beer.
- Oh, oh my.
(speaking Austrian)
- What's it?
- Like bon appetit.
- What am I eating?
(speaking Austrian)
- Okay, so what is (speaking Austrian)?
- It's meat.
- (laughs) I can see that.
I have to warn you, though,
if I keep drinking this,
this video's gonna go places.
(cheering)
So, what is Scnapps, though?
- Well, first, just try it
and then I'll explain, maybe.
Other way 'round.
I don't know if you'd still like it.
(coughing)
- I don't like that.
I'm so sorry.
I try to be respectful of all cultures.
(laughing)
How was that for you, Nicki?
You didn't like it either?
I need some pretzels.
I'm so sorry.
- I think the worst part
about it is it's too strong.
It's like 80 proof.
- It's 80 proof?
Are you...
- Yes.
- When I first told my team
about this video, I said oh,
it's gonna be this beautiful piece
about two people connecting in Vienna.
Less than one hour after meeting you,
I'm gagging on some Schnapps.
- There is different kinds.
- Of connections.
- No.
Schnapps!
(laughing)
- This is absolutely not
like what happened in Before Sunrise.
Ethan Hawke definitely did not
get drunk in Before Sunrise.
It's just (mumbles) Before
Sunrise to Before I Pass Out.
- [Elena] My aunt lives here.
- [Aria] Your aunt lives...
Do you wanna say hi to your aunt?
- I actually think she's sleeping by now
because it's...
- It's kinda late.
Yeah, it's true, it's almost midnight
and here we are wandering the streets.
What I'm gonna miss about Europe
is just how everything's so walkable
'cause in the US we don't walk anywhere.
- I know, it's so sad.
I really...
I missed it when I was there.
The walking...
- When you were in Wisconsin?
- Yeah, Wisconsin.
- Oh, do you like The Sound of Music?
- Actually, it's not a thing
that Austrians really watch.
- Oh my God.
- I'm so sorry.
- [Aria] So, what do you know
about Saint Stevens Cathedral?
- [Elena] Oh, you tell me
first and I'm gonna tell you.
- Saint Stevens Cathedral,
very old cathedral,
but apparently it houses, in a crypt,
the organs of Hofburg family royals
as well as the dead skeletons
of people who died in the plague.
Very romantic.
- I think it's kinda actually sad
that Saint Stevens Cathedral
isn't really that important
as a Viennese person.
We just walk by and we
don't really realize
how important it is
because if you live here,
you just don't really spend
- [Aria] You don't think
about those things.
- [Elena] too much time.
- [Aria] Let's be honest, how
crazy did you think I was?
- Well, at first I was like oh my God,
I feel so sorry because it's raining
and you were so excited about this,
and I was just so tired
and I was like oh my God, I can't do this.
But you know, you were so nice.
I was like, I have to do this now.
But then it turned out so great,
and...
- Yeah, how do you feel?
- I really enjoyed the evening.
It was so nice.
- Yeah, I think...
I think I've had a really great time.
(light piano music)
- You know, I believe if
there's any kind of god,
it wouldn't be in any of us.
Not you or me, but just this
little space in between.
If there's any kind of
magic in this world,
it must be in the attempt
of understanding someone
sharing something.
I know, it's almost important to succeed,
but who cares, really?
The answer must be in the attempt.
- It's sad that I just met
you, but everything has to end.
- But it's worth it, I think.
- Yeah.
You're gonna come to LA?
- You're gonna come to LA?
- Definitely.
Just invite me, I'll come.
(mumbling)
- I think it worked out the
way it was meant to work out.
I think there was
something very bittersweet
in the idea that I spent one
great night with a great girl
who I will maybe never see again,
but that's what life is about, right?
It's about making memories.
Yeah, it's about making memories.
(acoustic music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.